Wendy Williams gets emotional while
addressing her scary TV faint it was
scary it was really scary the talk show
host fainted in her Halloween costume
during Tuesday's episode of the Wendy
Williams Show on Wednesday the 53 year
old shut down rumors that it was a stunt
and explained what went down
I'm feeling like a ways how hot and like
something's about to happen hot and a
little dizzy but not like the room
spinning just like weird Williams was
treated by paramedics and eluded that
menopause might be to blame but a source
tells et that her staff is concerned
that stress was the real cause of the
scary moment you can believe what you
want but in September Williams shut down
speculation that her husband Kevin
hunter was having an affair but et's
source says wendy is quote in denial
about her marriage troubles and that
people close to her are concerned she is
quote going to completely lose it
because this is so catastrophic for her
the source adds quote to say she's not
handling the stress well is an
understatement